نحن نتمرن ونراقب ما نأكله ، لكن في
بعض الأحيان لا يتزحزح الوزن فقط ، فقد
يتبين أن المزيد من هذا
قد يساعد في قلب الموازين لصالحك ،
فهناك نوعان من الهرمونات المختلفة التي
تتأثر حقًا بقلة النوم أحدهما
هو الليبتين واللبتين  يخبر خلاياك الدهنية
أن تقلل شهيتك بشكل أساسي
والآخر هو
الجريلين ويخبر الجريلين جسمك بزيادة شهيتك
، وهنا
قد يؤدي تخطي النوم إلى مصدر خداعي آخر
لزيادة الوزن لدى الأشخاص الذين يظلون مستيقظين
لفترة أطول.  غالبًا ما تتناول وجبات خفيفة
ولكنها ليست أطعمة صحية ، لذلك
وجدوا أن هناك حوالي 300 سعر حراري
إضافي يميل الناس إلى تناولها وهي ليست
سعرات حرارية صحية ويمكن أن يؤدي ذلك إلى
زيادة الوزن وفقًا
لأطعمة تمارا ميلتون المتخصصة في التغذية الغنية
بالتريبتوفان مثل الحليب
الكربوهيدرات المركبة بالجبن والزبادي الموجودة في
الحبوب والمقرمشات والأطعمة الغنية بالألياف مثل
الخضروات والفواكه والحبوب الكاملة قد
تساعد في الحصول على نوم جيد ليلاً
وتخطي  في تلك الليلة ، قد يتسبب الكحول في
اضطراب نومك جنبًا إلى جنب مع
المشروبات المحتوية على الكافيين والشوكولاتة ، وذلك لمدة
ثماني ساعات وقد يساعدك ذلك على كسب
المعركة مع الميزان adam mccoy cnn